aslında Kimse
çocukken benim bir işte koro şefi Bir
müzisyen besteci olacağımı hiç
düşünmüyormuş Çünkü iki buçuk yaşında
kendi kendine okuma yazmaya başlamışım
Böyle olunca da Ben ailemin üzerindeki
hayalleri çok daha farklı işte geleceğim
parlak bilim insanı olacak herhalde
vesaire gibi düşünceler var tabi hayat
bambaşka bir yere götürüyor sizi
3 yaşındayken oyuncaklı melodikayla
böyle işte bir şey yapıyorum uğraşıyorum
bir yerlerden denk gelmişimlerden bir
hediye gelmiş herhalde duydum her şeyi
çalmaya başladım bunu fark edince
Bizimkiler bana böyle bir ufak bir Ordu
almıştı var mıdır böyle küçük orduları
olanlar üstünde böyle
davul seti falan olan işte hepimizin hiç
müzikle başlayan müzikle ilgilenenlerin
birçoğunda olan böyle küçük klavye
ordular O bitince onu bitirince Bir
büyüğü geliyor O da bir düğün klavyesi
arkadaşlar o anda E40 müzisyen
olanlarımız var mı bütün müzikle
uğraşanlar Belki bunu biliyorlardır
komşumuza danışmışlar karşıda
piyanistan'ın bir abimiz oturuyordum ne
alsak çocuğa ne önerirsiniz bu iyiydi
demiş Ben de orada Metin Şentürk'ten
işte ee seçmeler Kral TV'de o zamanlar
ne var ne yoksa her şeyi böyle yine
bütün imkanları sömürerek onu da
bitiriyorum bir yandan da okul yaşantısı
başlıyor çok ilginç bir okulda yaşansa
bunu detayına hiç girmeyeceğim 7
yaşındayken kilise konusunda şarkı
söylemeye başladım hayatımdaki herhalde
çok önemli noktalardan biridir çok sesli
müziği Türkiye'de içselleştirebilmemdeki
en büyük etkenlerden biri diyebilirim
orada kendi kendime not Okumayı Öğrendim
iyiden 70'e işte yeşilköy'deki işte
halkın böyle 15-20 kişilik her pazartesi
akşamı bir araya gelip bir şeyler
çalıştı Hem bizim birçok sesli aileniz
vardır Hem de dünya halk şarkıları İşte
hem Türkçe hem farklı dillerde
çalıştığımız bir topluluk
bir anlamda işte okulla derslerde hiçbir
zaman bir sıkıntı mı olmadı Hep Kendimi
şöyle hatırlıyorum işte gelirdim
okullarına ve çantamı bırakırdım hemen
daha böyle Üstümü başımı çıkarmadan
yapmamak yapacağım bir şeyler varsa
bitirir Kendimi dışarı atarım zaten ya
bir işte
antrenmanlarda işte okul takımının bir
antrenmana ya da işte bir modern dans ya
da halk oyunları provası şu bu vesaire
birçok şeyle ilgilendim Aslında ve
hiçbirine şunu diyemiyorum şu an
baktığım zaman yani şöyle hobilerim
vardı hiçbirine hobi gözüyle bakmadım
hep yaptığım şeyi en iyi şekilde
layıkıyla yapmak falan ki verdi ve
dolayısıyla da aslında o günden bugüne
çok fazla şey kalmıştır her
Ee ardından lise zaman lisede Beşiktaş
Atatürk Anadolu Lisesi'nde okudum orada
da tiyatro mesela hayatımı çok merkezine
yerleşti çok değerli bir hocamız vardı
Ali Kırıkhan teşekkür
lerimi onunla birlikte 4 yıl gerçekten
çok ciddi zamanımı ayırdığım ve böyle
çok şey öğrendiğim bir süreç oldu
tiyatroyum hayatımda bir yandan da
başlayan böyle aslında hiç Üstüne
düşmedim hiç de bugünleri ummadığım bu
Hikaye Böyle bir yol arkadaşı gibi benim
yanımda Benle beraber hayatında devam
ediyor
bir okul grubumuz oldu ben işte orada
Hem klavye çalıyorum işte notu okumayı
öğrenmişim kendi kendime çalıyorum
ediyorum o birikimle işte koroda şarkı
söylemeyi biraz öğrenmiştim şarkı
söylüyorum vokal yapıyorum düzenlemeler
yapıyorum biraz Gitar çalıyorum Her
şeyden biraz ufak ufak bir şeyler
yapıyorum işte festivalleri yarışmalara
katılıyoruz birincilikleri aldık Ee ki
bunlardan bir tanesi beni Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi ile tanıştıran yarışmadır
Battle Of The bandı diye dönemin önemli
bir amatör müzik grupları yarışması
hiçbir zaman da Manga Gripin gibi
grupların böyle kariyerlerine
başladıkları yarışma Biz lise grubumuzda
buraya başvurduk yıl 2004 yılı
unutmuyorum finale kaldığımızı
öğrendiğimizde lisenin koridorlarında
bir cumartesi Böyle günü yine prova
yapıyoruz orkestra odasında bağıra
bağıra böyle bir 10 dakika turlamıştık
bir türlü Çünkü çok büyük bir olay
Türkiye'nin her yerini açık işte yaş
ortalaması belki 30- olan
böyle katılımcılar var finalistler var
Biz sekize kalmıştık son 8'e kaldık
final günü de işte okulda herkes böyle
geliyor başımıza okşuyor falan ama büyük
başarı çocuklar hel
al olsun genç yaşta vesaire derken Biz O
Gün birinci olduk o yarışmada ve ben
işte bu şekilde hem Boğaziçi
Üniversitesi tanıdım hem Radyo
boğaziçi'ni tanıdım ve aklımda hiç ne
okuyacağıma dair bir şey yoktu ama
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi hep vardı
ilginçtir üniversite eğitimine O
zamandan başlayarak hep şöyle bilinçle
yaklaşmışımdır
yani böyle direkt bir meslek kapısı
olarak değil de hiç öyle bir hayalim
olmadı ama benim için üniversite eğitimi
demek elimizden uzaklaştığımız gerçekten
Türkiye'nin Hatta dünyanın dört bir
yanından bambaşka insanlarla bir araya
geldiğimiz kendimizi işte sınırlarımızı
potansiyelimizi ee keşfedeceğimiz
karakterimizi şekillendirecek olan Ee ve
bizi işte ergenlikten genç yetişkinliğe
doğru ulaştıracak çok kritik bir köprü
Bunu o zamanlar Belki böyle
tanımlamıyordum ama dönüp baktığımda
Aynen bunu hissettiğimi çok iyi
hatırlıyorum tercihim de o yüzden hep
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi
yanında oldu Ne okuyacağıma da şöyle
karar verdim aldım kataloğu elime ben ne
okursam acaba zevk alırım Beni zorlar
ilerleyebilirim derinleşebilirim İki
seçenek bıraktım psikoloji ve
matematiksel hesabı böyle bakıyordum
elledim üsttekini seçtim kazandım
başladım okumaya bir yandan TRT İstanbul
radyosu çok sesli gençlik konusunda
olarak söylüyorum Bir yandan birçok
grupla çalıyorum okul grubumuz devam
ediyor işte dışarıda biz devam ediyoruz
tiyatro topluluğumuz mezunlarla yine
çalışmalarına devam ediyor Aslında
üniversite ayak bastığım zaman benim
zaten
donum vardı halihazırda üniversitede de
koroların olduğunu öğrendim tanışma
gününde caz konusunun bir etkinliğine
denk geldim çok istedim ben de bir parça
sordum işte 15 Kişiydik bir topluluk
ve seçmelerin ne olduğunu öğrendim İşte
geçtim seçmeleri söylemeye başladım Bu
arada 2 yıl Ee o zaman işimiz Cihan'ın
asistanlığına yaptım orada
bir yandan söylerken 2 yıl sonra Cihan
Amerika'ya gitmeye karar verdi ve dedi
ki koroyu ben hani sana da öğretmek
istiyorum zaten Boğaziçi'nde öğrenci
kulüpleri bu sistemde yürüyor Hani
Senden sonra gelene devrediyorsun ve sen
kendi yoluna bakıyorsun gidin ben de
mutlulukla Tabii ki hani kabul ettim bir
şey yapmak istiyorum sadece dedim
herkese yeni baştan bir seçme yapmak
istiyorum Senin de rızanı olarak çok laf
söyleyeceklerdi bak En önemlisi şu bu
vesaire Ben eminim dedim Hani o
çocukluktan gelen bahsettiğim bir huyu
var ya bir şey olacaksa en iyisi olacak
layıkıyla yapmak bana
Ken Hele bir de bir şey sorumluluğu bana
verildiyse o artık gerçekten
olabileceğinin en iyisi nasıl olacaksa
öyle olmalı Gerçekten de çok söz oldu
çok karşı çıkanlar oldu yaptık o seçmeye
ama Ee 9 kişi başladık yıl içinde 5'e
düştük ama o ilk yıl daha önce hiç
yapılmamış şeyler yaptık ve gerçekten
Aslında o adamın neden atıldığının
altını bir şekilde doldurmuş olur
yaptığımız Bütün performansları Çok
beğenildi işte internette paylaşmaya
başladık bu zamanki gibi sosyal medya
yok Facebook var işte Facebook sayfası
açtık bir tane Ee Türkiye'nin dört bir
yanından beğeniler gelmeye başladı ve
bizi davet etmeye başladılar o yıl
başladık bütün üniversitelerde dolaşmaya
bir yandan İstanbul'dan festivale akmak
yastığı Festivali gibi önemli
platformlarda davet ediliyoruz orada
konserler yapıyoruz ve ilk yılımızda
Avusturya'da çok önemli bir akapıyla
Yarışması'nda iki gün üç diploma
kazandık orada da yine biz böyle 18-19
yaşında gençler yine Battle ben gibi bir
his yani orada da işte altıncı albümünü
bize hediye eden
gruplar harika bir deneyim ufkumuzu çok
genişletti ve 4 yıl üniversite çatısı
altında gerçekten çok fazla şey yaptık
ben o arada
2008'de matematik bölümünü bırakmaya
karar verdim müzik okumaya karar verdim
Yıldız teknikte bir yıl kompozisyon
okuyup Orayı da bıraktım Mimar Sinan
devlet konservatuarında okumaya başladım
Sonra bir yıl sonra orada da bir durdum
3 yıl sonra geri döndüm orkestra
şefliğine başladım bu sefer orada da
yine geri çıktım çünkü hayatında koro
yönünde çok yoğunlaşıyor bir parantez
kapatayım Şu an hala öğrenciyim sevgili
arkadaşlar Evet Mimar Sinan Güzel
sanatların Üniversitesinde Devlet
Konservatuvarı orkestra şefliği bölümü
Ee dalı lisans için öğrencisisin
karşınızda saygıyla eğleniyorum
bitireceğim pandemi ile bir yeni bir
heyecan geldi umarım seneye gidecek
hocalarıma buradan selam olsun
bugün finalim vardı dün beni aradı hocam
Eee eşim söyledi Eskişehir'e
gidiyormuşsun finale girmeyeceksin Oğlum
nasıl mezun edeceğiz Biz seni falan dedi
Öyle konuşmalar da oluyor tabii ki
hocalarımda o feda olsun bir şekilde
bitecek bir yandan koro çok yoğun devam
ediyor Ben işte okullar değiştiriyorum
vesaire hala Boğaziçi'nde ama koro
çalıştırmaya devam ediyorum 2014 kimse
inanmazken 25 kişilik bir kadroyla Çin'e
Koru olimpiyatlarına gittik son saniye
kadar direnerek yani destek Bizim için
her zaman en büyük sıkıntı Tabii ki
herkes gözümün içine bakarken böyle
artık vazgeçmez sizin için falan diye
Gerçekten bunu son saniye kadar
direnerek vazgeçmeyerek başardık bir
ikincilik iki üçüncülükle döndük 90
ülkeden 400 koronanın katıldığı devasa
bir etkinlik
döndük bu sefer 2011'de 35 kişilik bir
kadromuz var Dünya Arasında gitmek
istiyoruz Avusturya'ya
ya işte nasıl olacak nasıl edecek yine
paramız yok Eee tamam Eee ne yapacağız
ne edeceğiz sürekli konserler yapıyoruz
her konser çıkışı oturuyoruz böyle kafa
patlatıyoruz O az önce videoyu başlatan
bizim üniversite yollarımızı ayırdıktan
sonraki böyle yani onu Milat kabul
ederiz biz Metro videosu ortaya çıktı
o hikayesi uzundur Girmeyeceğim ama onun
sayesinde Türkiye'de yepyeni bir sayfa
açıldı yani işte koro müziği o zamana
kadar belki halktan kimse bilmiyordum
yani Çok az kişi biliyordu çok sesli
koro müziğini diyeyim Bir anda herkes
birbiriyle bu görüntüleri bu videoyu ve
başka performansları paylaşmaya başladı
Biz o hafta bütün ana akım Medya
organlarında işte haber programlarında
ana haber bültenlerinde Talk showlarda
gazete dergi Radyo röportajlarında
kendimize yer bulup ve Korona Türkiye'ye
tanıttık Aslında ve onun sonunda Zor da
olsa sponsorumuzu bulup şampiyonaya
gittik yine orada gördüğünüz İşte o
gururu yaşadık iki dalda Ee dünya
şampiyonluğunu kazandırdık Türkiye'ye ve
döndük
ülkeye ve çalışma yerimiz yok çünkü İşte
tam o dönemlerde Üniversiteye de çok
sıkıntı yaşıyordu ve şampiyona
gidebilmek için üniversiteye yollarımızı
ayırmak durumunda kaldık diye
özetleyeyim
ve üstüne inanılmaz Tabi bir hikaye
2012'de 100.000 Euro'luk bir borcun
altına girdik Ben 24 yaşındaydım
bilmiyorum burada hem yaşıtlarım hem
benden Gençler benden büyükler de var o
yaşlarınızda ya da bu yaşlarınızda şu an
zaten adını ağzımıza alamıyoruz maalesef
100.000 euro gibi bir meblağım gerçi
bugün ne oldu Hiç bilmiyorum herhalde 10
dakika önceden daha farklı
Yani öyle bir borcun altına girer
miydiniz İşte bir koroyu uluslararası
bir festivale yarışmaya vesaire götürmek
için bu soru böyle bir tarafımızda
Dursun isterim son sahneye kadar yine
uğraşlar işte çok olumlu giden bir
sponsor görüşmesi her şey bu sefer çok
iyi olacak derken ee seyahatimize iki
hafta kala bir telefon alıyoruz maalesef
Çok ani gelişen bir kriz sebebiyle Size
destek Olamayacağız
Ne yaparsınız yani 45 kişi böyle bakıyor
size Ee ama hepsini kafası düşmüş tabii
Çünkü imkansız bir şey yani
Velhasıl koordinatörümüzde bir yemek
yiyoruz o beni vazgeçirmek için beni bir
yere götürmüş yarım saat sonra ikimizin
elinde telefonlar herkes eşini dostunu
arıyor işte nereden 5.000 buluruz
şuradan 10.000 buradan bilmem ne şu
bankadan kredi alsak şuradan buradan
derken Biz o arada İtalya'ya gidip
döndük sonra Amerika'ya gideceğiz son
kişinin uçak biletini ben kendi uçuşuma
4 saat kala bilgisayar başında Kredi
kartı numarası gelen kredi kart numarası
girip alıp böyle evi terk ediyorum falan
böyle bir süreçte Biz Borç harç bütün bu
festivallere katılabildik İtalya Amerika
ve Macaristan'da ve birincilikler altın
madalyalarla döndük o riski aldığımız
için Aslında orada bizi izleyen Ee Çok
üst düzey festivallerin yöneticileri
direktörleri bize bu sefer davet etmeye
başladı
Onların da çok özledik hikayeleri var
Oraya da Girmeyeceğim ama önümüzde çok
yeni bir yol açıldı hatta biz o 100 bin
Euro'luk borç bir yandan kapatmak
zorundayız ve
5 yıl sürdü arkadaşlar 5 yılda
kapatabildik o borcu kapatabildik
Allah'tan öyle söyleyeyim Bir yandan hiç
durmuyoruz tabii ki sürekli dünyanın
Zirvesi olarak gösterilen festivallerde
Türkiye'yi temsil ediyoruz ve
yarışmalara gidiyoruz yine oradan da
yine birincilikler işte yine prestijli
ödüller kazanıyoruz ve genişlemeye
başladık 2014'te Boğaziçi gençlik
korusunu kurduk
2016'da makamat topluluğunu kurduk ilk
provasını 110 kişi yapmıştı sonra
Dolayısıyla içinden böyle bölünmelerle
birçok koro doğdu geldiğimiz şu noktadan
Boğaziçi Caz sorusuyla başlayan Hatta
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi Müzik kulübünde
başlayan bu hikaye Ee yaşları 14 ile 65
arası değişen Belki 5.000'e yakın tüm
Türkiye'den ve hatta çevrimiçi dönemde
pandemi döneminde tüm dünyadan da Ee
katılımcılarla aktif amatör koro
şarkıcılarıyla yolu buradan geçmiş
5.000'e yakın kişiyle bir yandan
Türkiye'nin 5 farklı şehrinde 5 farklı
dilde şarkı söyleyecek koroların
kurulmasına öncülük eden kültürlerin
sesli projesi vesilesiyle
toplumsal konularda sözünü hiçbir zaman
sakınmayan halkın içinde ve halkla
beraber olmayı tercih etmiş olan
en üst düzey müziği hedefleyen ve 3
kıtada 17'ye yakın ülkede kendi
müziğimizi kültürümüzü en iyi şekilde
temsil etmek gururunu yaşamış olan ve
bir yandan da Tüm türkiye'ye koro müziği
mucizesini yaymayı kendine ilke edilmiş
bunun için var gücüyle bütün
imkansızlıklara rağmen Ee yolculuğuna
devam eden milyonlarca seveni takipçisi
olan her gün belki de milyonlarca kişiye
ilham olan ilham veren ve o kadar da
kişiden ilham olan kocaman bir aile
olduk adına Magma ve Boğaziçi Has korosu
Ailesi dedik Ee ve bütün bunları
yaparken
bana Hep soruyorlar ben çünkü kendi
bireysel Kariyerim bir kenara attım Bir
yandan dünyanın dört bir yanına jüri
üyesi olarak davetliyim işte 6-7 yıldır
Önümüzdeki pazar günü Yunanistan'a bir
koro şefliği Master klasör ustalık
sınıfı vermek için davetliyim gibi böyle
bir anlamda Dünyayı geziyorum ama
aslında burada kalmayı tercih ettim bir
şekilde değil o son 10 yılda kesinti var
geçen yıl ona rastlayıp böyle çok
paylaşmıştım heyecanla onu sizlerle
paylaşmak istiyorum O soruya cevap budur
etkileşimi
çok zor mu Bence değil
Bana soruyorlar niye Türkiye'desin niye
yurt dışına gitmiyorsun ne işin var
burada diyenler var
çok işim var burada öyle cevap veririm
yurt dışına gitmek Tabii ki bambaşka
kapılar açan bir şey Orada yaşamak ve bu
müziğe orada icra etmek bütün imkanlar
çok daha yüksek Bütün bunlara rağmen
Bütün bunlar farkında yani niye
buradasın diyenler için de şunu
söyleyebilirim
burada kalması gerekiyor
Teşekkür ederim ben bu söze çok
inanıyorum ve özellikle de bu video hala
göstermeye devam ediyorum çünkü şu an
belki de bu sözün arkasında durmak çok
zorlaştı ve yani yurt dışına giden orada
bir hayat kurmak isteyenlere asla hiçbir
şekilde
yadırgamıyorum Çünkü burada yaşamak her
geçen gün daha da zorlaşıyor maalesef
ama şunu biliyorum ki gitsek de kalsak
da
burası bizim ülkemizde
bizlere ve özellikle de gençlere ve
onların dinamizmine Hayal gücüne
enerjisine Ee değiştirici dönüştürücü
azmine tutkusuna Ee çok ihtiyacı var ve
sevgisine Tabi ki o yüzden de bunu çok
önemsiyorum ve Eee Biz peki burada
kalarak ne yapıyoruz korolarla Eee
derdimiz nedir neden bu Torun müziğinde
bu kadar ısrarcıyız şunun için Sevgili
dostlar aslında hep hayalini kurduğumuz
huzur ve barış içinde birlikte yaşama
ideali var ya hani çok isteriz bunu
kardeşçe yaşamak Biz aslında koro müziği
yaparken Bunu zaten kendiliğinden
deneyimliyoruz Nasıl oluyor bu işte
birbirimizi daha fazla dinleyerek
Dolayısıyla birbirimizi daha iyi
anlamaya başlayarak yardımlaşarak
paylaşarak
sevgiyi dayanışmayı öğrenerek ve
farklılıklarımızı birer dezavantaj değil
birer zenginlik olarak görebilmeyi ve o
farklı renklerin oluşturduğu Harmandan
keyif almayı öğreniyoruz Yani aslında
farklılıklarımızla huzur ve barış içinde
birlikte yaşamayı öğreniyoruz gelin bunu
bir konuda nasıl deneyimliyoruz bir
konunun parçası olmak bir Kore'ye ait
olmak Acaba nasıl bir şeymiş koro
üyelerinin kendi ağzından yani
[Müzik]
çok aşırı güzel bir şey hikaye
bakabiliyorsun Aslında ve bence insanın
çakrasını çok geniş ve sanmışım Çünkü
gerek kültürel olsun gerek yani
larım bir ailenin parçasımış gibi
hissettiriyor
aynı dili konuşabildiğim insanlarla
olduğumu düşünüyorum Bir de şeyi çok
güzel Hani ailede de öğretecek gerilim
mi vardır ama aynı zamanda bir şey
vardır gırgır vardır saçma sapan
geyiklere doğru gider bazen her şey Ama
bazen de çok ciddi bir durum yani
sorumluluklar vardır Burada gerçekten
Utku'nun sorumluluğun Aşkın kavganın
gerilimin Hepsini bir arada olduğu bir
yer burası ve başka bir dil konuşuluyor
Bir de gerçekten mutluluk veriyor yani
hayatına Bence
herkesten olmayan Anılar katmış oluyor
cesaret katıyor bunu yapabildim başarısı
hissini duyuyorsunuz
bütünleştiğini yardımlaştık paylaştık
Bilmediğim şeyleri öğrendim Belki
birilerinde ben de bilmediğim bir şey
yok
[Müzik]
farklı insanlarla olmak farklı
insanlarla beraber aynı fiziki olmasa da
aynı ortamı paylaşmak ve aynı şeyi
konuşmak hoşuma gidiyor
böyle nasıl desem yani yanındaki de
aslında çok hissederek bir şey yapıyor
Sen de çok hissetli bir şey yapıyorsan
Yani bir sürü insanın hissederek yaptığı
şey tek bir noktada
buluşup Keşke bir de öyle tekrardan
sahnelerde söyleyebilsek daha da güzel
olacak orada olmak gerçekten hani onu
veriyor birlikte bir şeylerin
yapabilir beraber daha güçlü bir şeyler
çıkarabilmenin bir ortam bize yani çok
komik keyifli bir
şey yani başarı ayrı bir şey Ama
birlikte şarkı söylemek bile
işte aşkla yapmak
bu videoyla Biz Avrupa video ödülünü
kazandık 2021'de o yüzden de altında
İngilizce altyazılar var zaten kendini
çok güzel anlatan bir video hiç de
hesapta öyle bir şey yoktu ama öyle
güzel denk geldi ki dedik ki biz bu
videoyu daha yapalım oluşturalım ve
gönderelim
çok küçük bir anekdotla yavaş yavaş
bitireceğim
66 Avrupa genç müzisyenler Festivali
Belçika'da jüri üyesi Türkiye'den ve
2016'da da bu yarışmaya katılmıştık iki
dalda işte üstün başarılı unvanıyla
birincilik kazanmıştı 97 cevabı puanlar
mı Ee yarışmanın çok özel bir yanı var
yani festivalindeyim ödül töreni
yapılıyor ve hemen ardından Ee koro
şefleri ve jüri üyeleri bir araya
Geliyorlar getiriliyorlar yani böyle
güzel bir ortamda ve sıcağı sıcağına
birbirinizle izlenimlerinizi alışveriş
Ee yapabiliyorsunuz yani
paylaşabiliyorsunuz Ve bu çok öğretici
geliştirici bir şey Tabii ki 2016'da
olarak katıldığı bu buluşmaya 2018'de
şey Pardon konuşarak katıldım buluş
işte bütün
YouTube'da internette her yerde
bulabildiğim her şeyi koreografiyle
elinize kostümle elinize kadar bütün
repertuarınızı araştırdım teker teker ve
Sizden aldığım ilhamla
bir gençlik Korusu kurmaya karar verdim
ben ve işte eee bugün sizin karşınıza
çıktı burada
yavaş yavaş kapatırken sizce
tek şey var benim için bir şeye asla
Yapay Zeka dokunamaz hiçbir şekilde
karşılık gelemez Yapay Zeka hiçbir
şekilde o Her neyse onu Yerini Tutamaz
nedir o
yapıyor Yapay Zeka sanat ama neyi alamaz
Yapay Zeka insana dair
duygularımıza Hiçbir şey yapamaz sevgi
ve aslında bütün duygularımız biz de onu
yapmaya çalışıyoruz Duygu birliğini
sağlamaya çalışıyoruz ve bunu da aslında
sanatla yapıyoruz hill'in son kısmını da
izleyelim videonun ardından da kapatalım
yavaş yavaş
[Müzik]
acayip bir şey yani Herkesin aynı
şekilde hareket edebilmesi
benim benim
[Müzik]
kanalım rahatsızlığım var ve bu dönem
Benim için çok zor Geçti Benden enerjimi
çok düştü bazen hissettim kendimi Ama
buradaki bütün insanlar
bilirse
kimsenin daha önce yaşamadığı bir süreç
içinde bir rutini devam ettirmek bir
tanıdıklığın olması aslında herkesi
biraz da olsa rahatlattı Bence daha
böyle samimi hissettim daha böyle Yani
aslında Hayat devam ediyor Yani böyle
dışarıda böyle olaylara düşmem kötü
şeyler geçiriyoruz ama aslında bir
şeyler yine devam ediyor hayatımda benim
bulunduğum
yerler torunumu öğretebilirim kızımı
öğretebilirim yakınlarım öğretebilirim
öğrencilerimi öğretebilirim Yani
gerçekten paylaşabileceğim o kadar
düzgün bilgiler alıyorum ki sizden
[Müzik]
Ben acilde çalışıyorum ve Bu hastalık
bizi bitirdi artık yani o kadar
yorulduğumu hissediyordum ki artık
sadece hani yaşamlarını benim için mesaj
şeylerde ve ben sadece işe gidip
geliyordum yani Ve çok yoruldum
cumartesi nöbetten çıkıyorum pazara İyi
ki Prova var diyorum elime tekrar
tabanımı aldım
her
enerjiye fotoğraf çektirsem bir resim
yapalım yani ben de seçtiğimi hissettim
Aslında genç olduğumu hatırladım
Ben çok mutluyum yani hepsini seviyorum
diye sık geliyorum
Bu yüzden Diyoruz ki Türkiye'nin her
yerinde korularımız çoğalsın
çocuklarımız gençlerimiz çok sesli
korolarda şarkı söyleyerek büyütsünler
sevgiyi paylaşmayı dayanışmayı birbirini
dinlemeyi ve nice insani değeri
üyelerine katarak o değerlerle
yoğrularak yetişsinler ki işte o zaman o
çocukların oluşturduğu toplum dünyaya
çok daha farklı bakacaktır Buna sonuna
kadar inanıyoruz Bugün olduğu gibi
maalesef hala süren savaşlardan
kavgalardan bahsetmek yerine İşte o
zaman açlıktan sevgiden barıştan ve
kardeşlikten bahsedeceğiz ve inanıyorum
bunu da hep birlikte başaracağız O
yüzden Hepinize çok teşekkür ediyorum
bugün ben de
[Alkış]